because the people that lived on the
East Coast like I got to get the [ __ ]
out of here they kept going until they
got the californian they hit that water
my I don't want to live in Hawaii [ __ ]
yeah stay right here and then just the
breeding yeah yeah and then there's also
the entertainment business all the
pretty people from Cincinnati they got
on a bus yeah
I'm gonna make it look at these cheeks
yeah I'm gonna make it how many of them
make it very very very very very few
it's almost not even worth it put [ __ ]
out online online yeah for sure yeah but
I think people are still caught up in
the mystique of like coming to Hollywood
making it in Hollywood they even people
that do big things online they still
want to do like legitimate things like
I'd love to do movies you know who live
with your TV they want to do things that
pay them less money than they do being a
YouTube star yeah really YouTube pays a
lot of money now like if you're a big
like Logan Paul type dude yeah they make
he makes a shitload of money like who
[ __ ] pays him like who who signs his
cheque advertisements so someone
advocates these videos on the videos get
millions and millions of hits and he
gets millions of dollars from
advertisement revenue probably more
money than most successful sitcom people
yeah yeah if you think like someone
who's on a successful television show
you think well that guy's got to be
ballin I bet Logan Paul makes twice as
much money as those people [ __ ] I know
crazy and then there's people like pudy
pie how much does that guy make he's got
like 77 million subscribers so the but
the only thing about that guy is he
likes to say controversial [ __ ] and he
gets in trouble and then sometimes they
pull ads off of them stuff like that but
I think if you're one of those like
ninja Z another one that video game guy
those people make outrageous sums of
money outrageous sums of money like
playing video games and talking [ __ ]
yeah I saw it it was like this little
kid it was like a seven year old male 8
20 million dollars like that doing toys
yeah Ryan a Ryan's toy review that's the
kid at him he made 22 million in 2018 by
reviewing toys this little Asian kid I
got a little kid right there how much do
you think the parents
keep I tell my parents to suck my dick
he'll set up that [ __ ] video and
you'll clean my room this month will
here just raise the wiffle ball bake
Paul 21 million see look at that 21
million just by talking he had a Disney
show for a while he was on a Disney show
that my kids watch and then he decided
to [ __ ] that I'd rather just be in my
house what does it say on his wall team
team Paul team 10 that's a team 10 squad
he would like Pina down on his wall he's
got a man she's gonna [ __ ] up inside
they've got one of those Lego
installations to that some guy came in
and put Legos all in this wall no
interesting so who's number three let's
see this is a group of guys dude dude
perfect
they make like five man sports crew I've
seen those guys they do stuff with bows
and arrow
it just all kinds of thing they've been
doing it for a few years they've been
burning down like any kind of chick shot
you can think of so they made 20 million
dollars all five of them so 5 million
bucks each it's not nothing to sneeze at
and then what else this guy's so low
like damn TDM yeah and he made 18
million holla slash ball and I can go
anywhere
Oh Geoffrey star is that a guy or a girl
say Jeff makeup star makeup artist since
the myspace era has reinvented himself
as a beauty mogul wait a minute you say
himself are you misgendering him I
didn't miss gendered I think that's
whatever that is was this one marked up
video game choir 17 nobody ever see that
guy before that guy could go anywhere
meanwhile I made 17 million dollars
vanossgaming Canadian gamer Evan Fong
plays mainstream titles like the Call of
Duty plays games 17 million it's man
another one yeah 16 million look at this
guy who is pooty-poo like you benching
him before I never hurts another guy
that just he's a famous guy I don't know
too much about
watch them the most followed 17 2.5
million followers I think the reason why
he makes less money is because of the
advertisers have abandoned him because
he dropped some M bombs oh hey did ya
what does it say up there what does it
say about his uh no below him below
there swedish gamer the most followed
yeah a backlash last year rash of
anti-semitic videos that's right
anti-semitic he said he he but it was
like he was joking around in the like
was making fun of anti-semitic people
but while he's wearing a Hitler outfit
right too much work like you paid some
people like admit to make a fiber video
putting up signs that they didn't know
they just did it does that too yeah well
anyway point being you're right they can
make a shitload of money just being on
YouTube and on Twitch playing video
games guy I know that's real that's like
if you're a CEO of a gigantic [ __ ]
corporation you work 15 hours a day you
be super happy to make with these
[ __ ] man you're like you're right
like with the exception of a little kid
I'm gonna give a pass but the rest of
them dudes are just [ __ ] are YouTube
making money I mean I think you have to
be an [ __ ] to get attention to okay
that's like part of the thing you got to
be how would is miranda sings
is she in that list this is just the top
ten okay she's not the top here I mean
there's probably like a hundred people
that make seven million I know
so much mommy just give me so break me
on it
that's why I got my online project
coming out train pjj online.com yeah
dice